HELEN RILEY: Well,
hello everyone.
Thank you so much
for joining today.
My name is Helen Riley,
and I work in finance.
And I support the Lorraine
on Global Marketing,
as well as Patrick
and David Drummond.
And one of the best
things about my job
is that I head up
developments together
with Lisa Gevelber
for Women at Google.
And one of the new things that
we decided to launch this year
was a speaker series.
And so I reached
out to my colleagues
in the People Dev
organization, and actually
one of the first names that
came up was Sally Hegelsen.
And so I'm delighted to have
Sally come talk to us today.
So Sally is an internationally
acclaimed author and speaker.
She's done a number of
corporate leadership events
with a number of corporations--
well-known IBM, Microsoft, J&J,
HP, among others.
And she's also the
author of six books.
And her latest book is
called "The Female Vision."
I always mix up
feminine and female.
"The Female Vision."
So she's here today to
talk to us about some
of the lessons from
that book, and talk
about what it is to
articulate a clear vision.
How do we build allegiances
within an organization.
How do we project presence
and a have executive presence.
So a number of things she's
going to be talking about.
So I'm delighted to
hand over to Sally.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
SALLY HELGESEN: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It is a pleasure
to be here, and I
want to thank Helen
and Women at Google.
It's my first visit
to the campus.
And I love being here.
I love seeing all
the dogs around.
It just puts you in a great
mood, and all the bikes.
So it's a real pleasure.
And what I want to
do today is to share
some of what I have learned
over 25 years of researching
and working with women
leaders in organizations
all around the world.
And I want to focus
that on things
that you as women can do to
develop your own leadership
style, and for the men in the
audience-- both in the room
and out there in
different locations--
to also give you
some insights in ways
that you can drive some of
the best talent from the women
that you manage.
So I'm going to be drawing
a lot of information here.
I'm going to be focusing
on some of the things
that I learned both
in writing my most
recent book, "The Female Vision,
Women's Real Power at Work."
And some of the things that
I've learned in the years
since, because I've
worked with that material
to help women in hands-on
workshop and coaching
situations use the insights
and the research in that book
to strengthen their
own leadership style
and position themselves
well in their organization.
So that's what I'll be doing.
I'm going to do this in
pretty much three parts.
Briefly, I want to give
you a bit of background,
so you can understand where
this focus comes from,
the kinds of experiences
that drove it.
Then I want to
share with you what
I think of as two really red
hot insights from the book,
"The Female Vision."
And then I want to have a
real discussion about how
those insights can
be applied to you
in the management
of your own careers.
So let me start by giving
you a bit of background.
As I said, I've been
doing this for 25 years.
And my journey working
with women leaders
and researching
women leaders began
when I did the research that
became the book published
in 1990, called "The
Female Advantage,
Women's Ways of Leadership."
It has been continuously
in print, and was,
I'm very proud to
say, the first book
that focused on what women had
to contribute to organizations,
rather than how they
needed to change and adapt.
That had not been
out there before.
Like many books that really
hit a nerve with people--
I've never spoken, I once
had an Elvis impersonator
in the next room in Las Vegas--
but there's nothing we can do?
We've just got the music?
OK.
I'll try to groove with it.
The book came from my
very personal experience.
I had made a career shift
in the mid-late '80s.
I'd moved from being an
independent journalist
and writer to working
with corporate executives
and helping them--
writing their speeches
and working with them to
deliver their speeches more
effectively.
And in making that
change, I was concerned
about how I was going to be
perceived in the organization.
I felt like a double outsider.
There were very, very
few women at the level
that I was operating at.
So I did two things.
I studied the men around me.
And I also read a lot
of books, because there
were books that were being
written at that time for women
coming into organizations
about what they
needed to do to be successful.
And I got a lot from
what I was reading.
It was quite helpful to me.
But I noticed that
every single thing
I read focused on
how women needed
to change their
leadership style in order
to adapt to the workplace.
There was nothing-- there
was no acknowledgement
that women might have
something to contribute,
or that what they might
have to contribute
could be valuable
to organizations
in helping them
change and thrive
in a rapidly
changing environment.
One thing I've learned
is women are really
avid consumers of books about
what is wrong with them.
But it seemed to
be that there was
room to look at what
women could contribute,
and that that would be helpful.
So I decided to-- really
on my own initiative--
to start interviewing and
then doing diary studies-- so
shadowing-- some of
America's best women leaders,
to try to define
what it was that they
did that could be powerful
for other women to learn from.
And that could be
powerful for organizations
to understand what
they had to contribute.
The woman I studied
were very different.
Ethnically,
geographically, in terms
of what sector they were in.
There was a big range.
But what I found was there
were five characteristics
that these women, often very
different, had in common.
First, the women placed
a very high value
on the quality of
the relationships
that they built, but
also the relationships
that people generally
in their organizations
were able to build
with one another.
So they were very
relationship-focused.
The women had a bias for
direct communication,
rather than communication up
and down a chain of command.
They wanted to talk directly to
whomever something concerned.
The women liked
to put themselves
in the center of
things, and lead
from the center,
rather than the top.
Some of them even
put their offices
in the center of
their organizations,
and create what I
call webs of inclusion
to draw people in around them.
The women were comfortable
with, as opposed to tolerant of,
diversity.
They themselves
had been outsiders,
and had fresh eyes
for understanding
the kinds of things--
the kind of value
that an outsider
perspective could provide.
And they also knew from
personal experience
what condescending
behavior felt like.
And finally, the women
were skilled at integrating
their personal and their
professional lives,
and drawing on--
a number of them
said to me, made a
point of saying--
I'm the same person at work
that I am at home as a mother,
as a sister, as a wife, as
a member of my community.
And that gives me a
real source of strength.
And they were good at
drawing information
from their private life
and using it at work,
and vice versa.
Now what has been really
extraordinary in my experience,
is to watch over the last--
that was put out there in 1990--
and those characteristics
have become in the years
since, really thought
of, and often defined
as women's leadership
characteristics.
But what has been
amazing is to watch
the way in which those
characteristics have
become much more mainstream and
recognized as characteristics
of excellent leaders in general.
I've been able to
witness that, and it
has been really extraordinary.
And it is because
the environment,
the economic environment that
we're part of, technology,
and of course,
demographic change,
have all supported the
recognition of those leadership
characteristics as important.
As organizations have had
to connect more directly
with customers and
clients, they've
gotten more focused
on relationships.
I tell you when "The
Female Advantage" came out,
and I talked about that
value the women placed
on relationships, I was
told, don't go there.
Because talking about
relationships makes
it sound very soft.
And it's not good for women.
Now every bank wants to have
a relationship with you.
There's a real emphasis on
the value of relationships.
Obviously, comfort
with diversity,
more and more
important as we have
more diverse and
globalized workforce.
The ability to put
yourself in the center
of things rather than the top.
More adaptive as more work
gets done in teams and webs.
The ability to integrate
personal and professional,
again, more important,
more adaptive as we
move into a 24/7 environment.
And obviously a bias
for direct communication
is more and more of a
necessary skill given
the nature of
network technologies.
So it has been extraordinary to
watch this sort of confluence
between what I saw women often
bringing to organizations where
these characteristics had not
been defined as leadership
characteristics, and the way
in which the environment was
demanding these qualities.
In fact, it was so interesting
to me, a couple months ago,
Tom Friedman, the New
York Times columnist,
did a series called
what it takes work
at Google, in which he
interviewed Laszlo Bock,
and talked about what leadership
characteristics Google was
looking for.
And I wrote a blog about it--
because I blog for "Strategy
and Business" magazine--
the extraordinary overlap
between what Bock was describing
as desirable characteristics
for leaders, especially
collaborative skills,
relationship
building, the ability
to work seamlessly
in webs and teams,
and assume different
positions within them,
putting yourself in the middle.
And I thought it
is extraordinary
that what Bock is describing,
25 years ago, 20 years ago,
were really considered
women's leadership strengths.
And I think that has been very
much to the advantage-- not
only of many women,
but it has also
freed many men to explore
other sides of themselves,
and recognized
that they could be
strong leaders while doing that.
So I think it has been
a very good thing.
That said, about
2006 or 2007, even
I, who tend to be a "glass
half full" type person,
began to think, now there's
something amiss here.
If women are bringing these
skills often to organizations,
and these skills are becoming
recognized more as mainstream
leadership skills, and
organizations are often
hiring women at 50%, and women
are becoming increasingly
represented at the top in terms
of business and professional
schools, why aren't
they are more women
at the very top, where they're
making the kinds of decisions
that have the real strategic
influence on the direction
of their organizations, and
on our society as a whole?
Why is there a leadership
barrier, or gap, still
in place, especially
given this confluence
between what women bring and
what organizations increasingly
need?
And what caught my
eye as I pondered
this-- and a lot of other people
who are in this field generally
were thinking about
that then, and still
are-- what struck me were two
studies that I came across,
one down in Madrid, one
down at INSEAD, sort
of the HBS of France and
Europe generally, both of which
were big global studies,
and both of which
showed the same thing.
What they showed is that when
interviewing senior leaders
in organizations about where
they saw women's strengths
and women's weaknesses, the
kinds of characteristics
we've been talking
about-- collaboration,
relationship building,
direct communication,
negotiation-- the
senior leaders felt
that the women in
their organizations
demonstrated them.
But consistently what
those senior leaders
said, point where they
felt women had a weakness
or needed to develop
more strength,
was around the question
of vision, big picture
thinking, long-term focus.
So the executives in these
two huge global studies
were critical of
their women in terms
of their capacity
for vision and this
was an impediment to women's
perception of being ready
for leadership.
And what was fascinating
also in the study,
because women often routinely
tend to under assess themselves
and their skills based on how
they're perceived by others,
is the women didn't
see this gap at all.
The women felt that they
had a strong vision.
That they represented long-term
thinking and big picture
focus very well.
So I thought, something
isn't translating here.
Maybe it's time to
explore what vision really
is in organizations, and where
there may be a gap, where
women's vision may not be
translating in organizations,
so that it can be understood
and recognized and valued
by senior leaders.
Doing that seemed to me an
extremely worthwhile project,
because in doing so, I thought
there's an opportunity to,
on one hand help women
to better understand
the nature of their
vision, and articulate it
in a way that can be
heard, and at the same time
there's an opportunity to
help organizations recognize
the power of vision that women
have the capacity to bring.
So this became my quest.
This became sort of in my
view, the next frontier
that we needed to research and
get some ideas and some answers
for, in terms of the next area
to think about development
of leadership
capacity for women.
So that's what I
began focusing on.
And I want to very briefly share
two insights from the really
huge research project that
I undertook with a team
to identify and articulate
what the female vision is,
and where its
power could reside.
And then we'll open
it up and start
to look at what does this
mean for you next Monday
morning, in terms of building a
leadership style that can lead
you to make a contribution
that really reflects your best
talents, your true talents, and
create a career for yourself
that's very satisfying in
the course of doing that.
The two insights, so I
want to do this briefly.
The first one-- and this I
think, is really a big deal.
What we learned.
Not just from doing
interviews and case studies,
but also from working with some
neuroscientific labs at UCLA
and Columbia that
were doing research
on what happens when people's
brains are operating.
What we learned is that--
now of course we're human,
so there's always
a spectrum here,
it's not all men are this way
and all women are that way.
But what we learned is that
in general, women's attention
tends to operate in
some distinctive ways.
What women notice, which is
a building block of vision.
Think about, what is vision?
Vision is what you notice.
Then it's what you value
about what you notice.
And then it's the
story you tell yourself
about why what you're
noticing is important.
So notice is really the
building block of vision.
This primary building block.
And what we found is that women
tend to notice a lot of things
at once.
And this is verifiable
in neuroscientific labs
when they hook people
up to functional MRIs
and watch the
brain in operation.
Women are noticing
all the time, they're
noticing different
things at once.
Their attention is scanning and
operating kind of like a radar,
and they're processing in
parallel a lot of information
from different sources.
Whereas men tend to have a much
more focused style of noticing,
looking at one thing
at a time, focusing in
on it, with their
attention operating
more like a laser,
rather than a radar.
And this matters.
This matters when we
think about leadership,
because in many organizations,
in many organizations,
focused notice is perceived of
and privileged as a leadership
style.
And those who have a more
broad spectrum notice,
as we called it in the book,
are thought of sometimes
as being all over
the place by those
who have very focused notice.
I can give you an example,
a day to day example
of how this operates and what
some of the consequences are.
Right here in the Bay Area, I
spent some time with a woman--
Susan Bernstein,
she had got her MBA,
she joined a hotshot
consulting firm.
And when she came in, she was
told, your first big client
case, your first proceeding,
I want you to go to that.
Don't say anything.
Just notice.
Just notice what is
going on in that room.
So Susan went to the
meeting, and she noticed.
And what she noticed was
that the two chief clients
on this project couldn't
stand one another, nor could
their staffs.
It was in their
body language, it
was a real feeling of
tension in the room.
And when she came back to her
meeting and she was asked,
what did you notice?
She said that.
She said what I
noticed, the big thing
I noticed is that these
two guys seem to be at one
another's throats.
And what she was
told was, that's
not what you were
supposed to notice.
You're not there as
an HR consultant.
You are there as a
business consultant.
What you were supposed to
notice was the presentation
and the numbers.
How did you think they added up?
And she said, I went away from
that meeting thinking, boy
did I blow it.
I will never do that again.
And she said, I spent
the next seven years
in that organization
suppressing my capacity
to notice what was going
on among people, so
that I could better
fit the mold.
She said, and the result of
that, the result of that,
was that I lost my passion
for what I was doing.
Because I felt inauthentic.
I felt as if I was
constantly using energy
to suppress what my
best observations were.
And she said, and oh
by the way, six months
after I joined that team,
that project blew up.
And it blew up not because
the numbers were poor,
but because these two guys
were at one another's throats,
and ended up in a lawsuit
that, in fact, involved us.
She said, so there
was a real consequence
for me suppressing that.
But I still knew,
and I was given
to understand that that
information was not
what my company
wanted me to hear.
So there's an
example of the cost
of suppressing the power
of what you notice.
It seemed very,
very clear to me.
And one of the things that
I have come to believe
is that this capacity
for broad spectrum notice
is something that
in 10 or 15 years,
we will really recognize
as a leadership attribute,
in the same way that we
have come to recognize skill
at collaboration,
relationship building,
and direct communication as a
strong leadership attribute.
I think that because
organizations
are changing so rapidly,
and innovation is so much
a part of where organizational
value gets defined,
that that capacity for
broad spectrum notice
will become more important.
And the more prepared
we are to recognize
what it is, and articulate its
value in a way-- and this it
what we'll be getting to
int the sort of how to part
of this-- that laser-like
noticers can understand,
the more opportunity we'll
have to position ourselves
for leadership and for
being able to leverage
the power of that.
I think that's going to happen.
About a couple months after
the female vision came out,
I read an interview with
Jeff Immelt, the chair
and CEO of GE.
And he was asked, what is
the number one leadership
capability that GE is going
to be hiring for and training
for in the years ahead.
And what he said
was, the capacity
to see around the
corners, because that's
what's needed in
today's environment.
And I thought, how are you
going to see around the corners
unless you're skilled at
harnessing both broad spectrum
and focus notice.
When they work together,
you've got an opportunity
to get more information than
you would if it were alone.
So I'm going to
stop for a moment,
because that's a certain
amount of material.
I do have one other
insight from the book,
and then we'll drill
down more on to asking
you to think about how
this might apply to you.
But are there any questions
here on the question of notice,
or on the leadership
capabilities that we've
been discussing, or the way
in which those have become
more recognized as mainstream?
Has that been your experience?
Do have anything that
you can share on that?
AUDIENCE: It's actually
rather enlightening for you
to say that that
broad spectrum notice,
or women aren't
considered to have
much vision is one of the
things you want to point out,
because actually I left my
last role because my manager,
a male manager, said I didn't
have any strategy or vision.
And I said, well you're
ignoring the project
I've been spending
most my time doing,
which is a strategic
vision for the next step.
And I came over here
to Google in order
to work for a woman
who I think thinks
I have strategy and vision.
I think my question then is,
if you feel that you do have
strategy and vision, how do
you express that to someone who
thinks you don't?
SALLY HELGESEN: Someone
who thinks you don't.
So this will get
us a little more--
we can do this-- move
into some of the practices
that I've been talking about,
that we'll be focusing on here.
So let me get into that
and answer your question.
Because I think that's sort
of the key question here.
How do you-- if you think,
like the women in the study--
if you think you've got strong
vision and a strategic way
of thinking, how do you--
as it were-- translate that
to somebody who may have
a very narrow noticing
style, and therefore is judging
you as someone who doesn't,
because you're not
articulating it in ways
that they're comfortable with.
How do you do that?
And most of this
I've really learned
since the book came out,
working with women to develop
their capacity to articulate and
translate what their vision is.
A couple things that I think
are important, and some of them
come from talking to Susan
Bernstein afterwards,
seven, eight years afterwards.
One of the questions
I asked her is,
what would you have
done differently,
when you came into
that meeting and said,
I noticed these two guys were
at one another's throats?
Is this is there a different
way you would have handled that?
And she said a
couple things that I
think are really helpful in
thinking about how to do this.
How to translate this capacity.
She said first of all,
these are real data guys.
They're MBAs, they think,
live, breathe, eat numbers.
She said, first of
all, I would have gone
and in the first
thing I would have
done would be to address
what they were interested in,
and show them I saw the numbers,
this is how I perceived them,
whether than saying, this
is the main thing I noticed.
She said because
right away, what I
learned with them
is they were going
to see that as, to
some degree, off topic.
So getting out of
the way addressing
what I understood
was important to them
would have been helpful to me.
She said, secondly,
I should have
been more data-like in my
presentation of what I noticed,
rather than just saying,
and I noticed this.
And then trying to
give the details.
You know, so and so's admin
seemed to sit in a place
that the other
admin-- you know, all
these kind of little details
that she was giving to justify
or explain what she noticed.
She said, I wish I had presented
that more as data, going
in and saying
something like, here's
what I noticed
about the numbers.
Here's what I think is
important about that.
I will say that in order
for this to happen,
and that to happen,
we need to have a real strong
commitment from the two
principles, because here's
one way that could fall apart.
Here's another way
that could fall apart.
So that I was really explaining
to them why I thought
it was important for them,
for their bottom line,
for what they were
concerned about.
That these two principles
were on the same page.
She said, and then
if I had said,
and I have concerns about how
long-term their commitment
to one another is.
And I can share with you the
reasons for those concerns
offline.
She said, because
in a way, these guys
were a little bit uncomfortable
with that kind of material.
So I can explain
that to you when
we're offline, if you'd like.
But I have concerns.
And here, I think, are some
of the potential consequences
for us, for our division,
if there are problems
down the line.
Here are a couple scenarios.
She said, I could have
even had a slide or two
about what these scenarios were.
She said, in other words, if
I had really translated that
into a style of presentation
that they were comfortable
with, rather than presenting it
as very contextual and almost
as they would see
it, subjective,
I think I would have
had a better shot.
She said, but the
other thing I learned
is the big mistake I
made was to back off.
And to immediately
think, oh boy, I blew it.
And to take that to heart
and pull away from it.
She said, I should have gone
in there really prepared
to not argue the case,
but present the case,
for why this was important,
and represent that.
She said, because that's
really the vision part.
She said, my vision here is we
needed to address this issue.
We needed to
recognize this issue.
We needed to be prepared
for the kinds of things that
could go wrong
because of this issue.
That was my vision.
That's what I saw.
She said, I needed to explain it
in terms that they understood.
And I needed to be
prepared to defend myself,
instead of just
quickly backing off.
So I think that's sort of the
take away here, is be prepared
to-- I don't want to use
the word defend it-- but be
prepared to back it up
and stand your ground.
But know that in presenting
what you have to present,
if you're presenting to a very
bottom-line, get the point,
focused notice
boss, you want to be
able to articulate that in a way
that they are comfortable with.
And where they're
not being asked
to imagine a situation
that they're not
very good at
noticing or judging.
Because that's going to
then make them feel like,
how did I miss that?
Is there something
wrong with me?
Clearly not.
She's one of these
touchy-feely women who's
all concerned about what
people's relationships are
with one another.
That's not really
what we're here for.
We're business consultants.
So she said she
could have really
handled that differently.
And understood that
bringing both perspectives
together could be
really valuable.
There's one other
thing I want to say,
because I've gotten very aware
this of kind of presentation
since the book came
out and since I've
worked with some women, I worked
down in San Diego for a while
with women in a
biotech firm, who
were having real
problems presenting
what some of their
research points are,
because they were
getting critiqued
as being all over the map.
So we were really trying
to almost reverse engineer
and figure out what do you
need in this presentation
about this data?
What is going to set
these guys at ease?
And in watching, because
I did some role playing.
But in watching some
of the presentations,
here's one thing I
saw over and over.
Women would often start
with a kind of back story
to let their listeners
know how they came up
with what they came up with.
So they'd begin,
you know, I'm going
to tell you how I came
to this research point.
And I'll tell you this
research point in a moment.
But let me tell you
how I got there.
Let me tell you the process
by which I got there.
I was having a
conversation with so an
so-- you've lost them already.
If you've got a really
tightly focused focus
noticer, a laser-light
guy, his mind
almost clicks off when
you start to tell him
what the back story is.
Much more powerful-- because
we've gone through this,
we've gone through this process
and watched it work-- much more
powerful, is to be
able to present it
in a very focused,
data-like way.
And then say, if you're
interested at some point in how
I got to this, be glad
to share it with you.
But not do it as the opener.
Because often women
use personal stories
to establish relationship as
a way of sharing and preparing
to share information.
And often, not
always, there are men
who are very
different than this.
But often with men in
real business situations,
that's not cultural for them.
And it's not something
they're comfortable with.
So it can certainly
be surmounted.
And this was one of my goals
in developing and looking
at what is a female vision?
How can that be incorporated?
Part of it is how
do we interpret it?
So, great question.
Does that help?
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: About describing
being things to an audience that
is more laser-like in their
focus, and starting with data
and then offering to
tell a personal story
if it would be
helpful at the end.
SALLY HELGESEN: Correct.
AUDIENCE: I feel like striking
that balance is really hard.
I know that when I in
the past have started
with telling a personal story
or making a personal connection,
that it has been met at
times with skepticism,
and then you lose your audience
and you can't get it back.
And I feel like I've
over corrected now.
Now I feel like I don't
talk about myself as often.
I don't make those
personal connections.
I don't share those
stories, because I've over
corrected after having been
met with this skepticism.
SALLY HELGESEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I do feel
like, especially at Google,
it's helpful to tell
those personal stories
and make those personal
connections even
with people with the
laser-like focus.
And so getting it right here,
I think, has been a challenge,
because I understand what
you're talking about,
but I feel like this environment
may be a little unique.
At least on the legal team,
I think, where I work.
SALLY HELGESEN: I love
that, because I have watched
women do this.
And the biotech team
that I was working
with for a while,
that began to happen.
They began to, OK
we're going to do this.
We're going to do
the data thing.
And suddenly they had
lost their personality.
And women are often very
ripe to be criticized.
And it was like,
well she's a robot.
She doesn't seem to have
any warmth or personality.
This is what happened
to Susan Bernstein.
The woman up in the Bay
Area, up in the east bay.
When she said, I lost who I was.
I lost part of what my
authentic value was.
And she said, I began
to-- I remember years ago
I read a fantastic quote
from a woman that just,
to me, epitomized
what happens when
you lose your
authenticity at work.
She said, sometimes I feel as
if my body is only a vehicle
to carry my head
to the computer.
And to me, that sort of
encapsulates everything
we want to avoid as people.
And I think that comes
when you suppress
what's good in yourself.
So what you're doing, what
you're noticing, that you over
corrected, is part of
a process, I believe,
of coming to a very strong
and authentic way of being
in the world and
presenting yourself.
On one hand, you have the
confidence and the humility
to notice that the way
you were presenting
wasn't necessarily landing
in the way you wanted.
So you made correction.
But then you're open
to also noticing
that you corrected
too far, and you're
searching to find
that balance point.
But you can't search to find
that balance point unless you
are aware of what
both feel like.
And it sounds as if you are.
So I would say is
that this is really
part of this process to
getting toward a very
strong and authentic way of
presenting what your vision is.
And that one of
the things, I hope,
is that being able to
recognize and articulate
some of these
differences-- putting it
in the frame of laser
and radar notice--
and recognizing where your
own capabilities and comfort
level lie, that
that in itself can
be helpful in identifying
what the issue is,
and then coming to understand
how to take action.
OK.
Let me go to the one other
quick insight from the book
that I'd like to share.
And then we'll do
more of this in terms
of focusing on what
it means to you.
We talk about vision
as what you notice,
then the next step
is what you value.
So one thing we
really wanted to learn
was what are the similarities
and differences in what men
and women really value
about their work,
about their experience in the
organizations they're part of.
Where's that overlap?
How does that happen?
So we ran out a
big-- because when
you ask a question
about what you value,
it can be pretty abstract--
so what we did was
we ran out a big study looking
at similarities and differences
in how men and women perceive,
define, and pursue satisfaction
at work.
And what we found--
so it was a big study,
we used Harris
Interactive to deliver it.
It was a huge sample of
people in a variety of levels,
director and above
in organizations.
And what we found is that there
were some strong similarities
between what men
and women valued.
They wanted to be recognized.
They wanted to feel
authentic at work.
They wanted to be recognized
for their real achievements.
They took great
satisfaction in being
a part of a team
or leading a team.
And they took great satisfaction
in achieving goals and being
able to check those off.
But we found two areas
of significant difference
in terms of value.
And I think this has
a real impact in terms
of how you think about your
vision and positioning yourself
in the organization.
The two areas that
were different
were, first of all, women tended
to define their success based
on their own terms that
they had set for themselves.
Whereas the men in
this study really
defined success
almost exclusively
in competitive terms.
I came out ahead of him.
And therefore I'm satisfied.
So it was very
competitive in terms
of how they perceive
success, whereas women
were more likely to have their
own benchmarks for success.
And the other thing was
that women were more
focused upon and tended
to judge as satisfying
the everyday experience
of work that they had.
Whereas the men that we
studied were more likely to
perceive satisfaction based on
position and monetary reward.
Position and monetary reward
were important for women,
not saying that.
But they were important to women
in the context of also having
a satisfying
experience of everyday.
And that experience was
often defined by the ability
to develop high
quality relationships
and maintain them over time, and
by the capacity to some extent
control their own pace at work.
And these differentials,
I think, really do matter.
And when we think about it,
one of the things that we see
is that organizations,
given this,
often define motivation
or assume motivation
based on primarily
male criteria.
The idea is competitive ranking
will be a spur to performance.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
It's kind of a diversity issue.
Competitive ranking
isn't going to be
a spur to performance
for everyone.
And yet, we see, I mean we even
see organizations even now,
adopting these
competitive curves, which
can be very problematic.
And then this strikes me as
not much of an issue here,
which makes my heart
sing, I will say.
It seems that there's
real attention
here to what the quality
of people's experience
is, at least from the optics.
And that is really important
for creating organizations
that really motivate women
to develop their best.
What is the everyday experience.
One thing we found when
we interviewed women
who had left high positions
they were very monetarily
satisfying, what we
found they tended to say
was, to do something else.
They'd say, I decided
it just wasn't worth it.
Meaning, while the money
and the position were great,
those weren't as
profoundly intrinsic
to what my values were, because
my every day experience was not
fulfilling.
Because I didn't feel like I
had any control over my pace,
for example.
I didn't feel that I
could tell value that.
So I think it's really
important in organizations,
and this is something
for everybody
who's out there to think
about, to some extent,
we're looking at diversity
as an issue so often,
but motivation is a
diversity issue as well.
People are motivated
by different things.
And it's really helpful
for us as individuals
to recognize what
really motivates us,
and to share that information.
Because that's helpful
to the organization.
It's helpful to our bosses.
What really gets us engaged?
And it's not going to be
the same for everyone.
I think that's an
important point.
Any question or
observation on this?
AUDIENCE: So in my old
job in public accounting,
I felt like every time
there was a happy hour
or an employee appreciation
thing, it was always like,
here's a bunch of
food and alcohol.
And it was like
that was kind of how
they felt they were like paying
people back, or thanking them.
And I tried multiple times
to talk to HR and say,
I would much more appreciate
a massage, or a spa day.
Or something where
I could relax.
That was what would make
me feel appreciated.
As opposed to, here, you
just worked 80 hour weeks,
so drink all the
alcohol you want.
Like get your money
back that way.
So I think it was
never something
that they really valued,
or really tried to change.
Or let's do a wine
tasting class.
If you want to do alcohol,
let's do something a little bit
different than greasy
food and a happy hour.
So that was just an
observation, for that.
Like not listening
really, or really trying
to see what would
motivate people or make
them feel appreciated.
SALLY HELGESEN: And
it sounds like there's
a reason you're
not there anymore.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SALLY HELGESEN: And it's a
kind of mismatch of values.
And I think more
and more, I mean,
this is one of the
gifts that women
and also I think a younger
generation, which is well
represented here, of
workers, are bringing in.
Being more in touch with
what really motivates them.
A greater understanding
of that, and a willingness
to do what you did, which
was to try to tell them.
There are people
here who find this
highly motivating and rewarding.
Then there are people
like me, who don't find it
that motivating.
Why not look more
broadly to think
about what could engage people.
And what I see
with organizations
is more focus on how do we
engage diverse employees?
But often not thinking about
that in terms of motivation
and reward.
And I believe that
is something that's
going to be changing
over the next 10 years,
that there's going to be a much
more recognition that-- I mean,
in the old days they'd give
recognition to a male executive
would be a mink
stole for his wife.
You know, how
generic can you get?
So we're moving to something--
that's kind of the Madman era--
we're moving to something
that is much more customized.
And we're really part of that.
Three things.
Looking at what this can
mean for those of you who
are here and out there,
in terms of how you think
about your own
leadership capacity.
We've talked a bit
about how important
it is to articulate
what you see.
The power of what you see.
The value of what
you notice in a way
that those who have a
different spectrum of notice
can understand.
The-- if you would,
responsibility
to think about how you're going
to translate that in order
to really stand
behind it strongly.
But there's another aspect
of the notice duality
that I think is
important to understand.
And it has to do
with not expecting
those who have a
very focused notice
to notice certain
things about you.
Had a great example of it
right here in the Valley.
Was a young woman
engineer-- was it
electronic arts, or something?
I'm not remembering because
it was a big workshop.
Anyway, she-- Ellen Isaacs.
I do remember her name,
and I remember her face.
And we were talking about
this noticing business
and what different
people notice.
And she said, I had the
best example of that.
This really helps me
understand something.
She said, I've always
thought of myself
as a real go-to person
in the organization.
People contact me about
things that might not even
relate directly to my job.
I get lots of calls,
lots of emails, people
in and out of my office.
She said, and a couple
weeks ago we went off site
on a retreat, where we had
our performance review done.
She said, and my boss was there.
My performance review came back.
We had a talk about it.
She said, and basically what
he said was, she's terrific.
She does very high quality work.
But she's not broadly enough
connected in the organization.
She seems to spend a lot
of time in her office.
And she thought, what?
The very thing I think I'm
best at, he doesn't notice?
How can that be possible?
And she said she spent some time
after that really feeling bad.
Wondering if she should work
for the guy who she really
liked working for, and just
kind of taking it to heart.
She said, I feel like I had
been punched in the stomach
to be criticized on the thing
I felt I was best about.
She said, but listening
to this-- she said,
what I realized
is I was expecting
him to notice something that
may not be in his radar span
for noticing.
How would he know how
broadly connected I am?
I never told him.
He doesn't monitor my email,
see who comes into my office.
He doesn't monitor
my phone calls.
I had never told him.
She said, so what I
realized I had to do
was come up with a way to
share this information with him
explicitly.
So she began a kind of program
for herself where she--
every two weeks she sent
him an email saying,
talked to so and so, connected
these two people, et cetera,
et cetera.
She said, I felt so
nervous about doing that.
I feel so frightened
about doing that.
I thought he was going
to say, why is she
wasting my time with this?
Why is she blowing her own
horn all of a sudden to me?
She said, his response was, this
is information I need to know,
because what you're doing
is strengthening me.
Because you work for me, you
are building my connections,
and I need to know
that information.
So she had a real recognition
of the power of handling that
well, and getting past
this sort of shyness
about articulating what
she was doing to her boss.
But really also
recognizing, I went
in there expecting he
would just notice things
that I might notice, even though
I had plenty of information
to let me know that that's
not how he saw things.
He wasn't-- I wonder
what Ellen's doing?
I wonder if Ellen
knows this person.
It wasn't on his radar screen.
It's not really how he thinks.
So that's the other
side of the notice.
So you're thinking
about vision, and I
think it's really
important for us
to articulate and to
have in mind really
an idea for describing
what our vision is.
Whenever we are
in a job, what is
my vision for what I could
be doing in this job,
and how does that
fit with the larger
vision I have of what could be
helpful for this organization?
The more you can articulate
that, and have it
almost in your back pocket,
the more powerful it will be.
But also, what's
great about doing
that is you can use the
vision that you have
to begin to build allies
in a very strategic way.
In organizations
today, there's so much
emphasis on getting a mentor,
and getting a sponsor, and all
that.
And I thought
Sheryl Sandberg did
a great job of addressing
why that can sometimes
be problematic.
Certainly I have
worked in organizations
where the women who are
in very senior positions
are besieged with requests to
be mentors and sponsors, often
in a way that's
somewhat inorganic.
And I think that
the emphasis on it--
although it's a very, very
helpful and important,
and I've seen organizations
where women's opportunities are
transformed by mentoring
and sponsorship programs.
But sponsors and mentors
are one kind of ally.
And allies can be peers, they
can be people who report to us.
They are people who are
engaged in helping you achieve
what you want, and who
recognize that in doing that,
they can strengthen
themselves as well.
That's what an ally is.
So it's not necessarily a level.
And I believe that women can
really strengthen themselves
by using the vision that they
articulate to enlist allies.
Women are great at building
relationships in general,
but they're not always as great
at leveraging relationships,
as making sure those
relationships help them achieve
what they're trying to achieve,
and helping the people who
are allied with
them also achieve
what their objectives are.
Often we can be shy about saying
this is what I'm trying to do.
This is how you can help me.
And this is how you
can benefit from that.
And, oh by the way,
what can I do for you?
One thing I've noticed, and
I've had this discussion
often with people
in HR, and I've
had this discussion with
headhunters as well.
Women will come into
a position and think,
I need to get
really good at this.
I'm going to keep my head
down for the next six months.
And I'm going to
master this job.
And then I can look up and start
to bring people in around me.
Whereas often you'll find
a successful male will
go into a job, and
his first question is,
who do I need to
reach out to who
can help me make this a success?
So right away he's
engaging people,
who is going to help me
be successful at this?
And the result is that he
has more support and more
visibility for what he does.
That keeping your head down
and trying to become an expert
can cost you in terms of
visibility and support.
So it's something that
I always have urged.
And the reasons and the
techniques around it
change over time, but for
women, it's really important
to think once you have
articulated what you're
trying to do, who can
help me build this?
How can I bring people in?
How can I leverage their skills?
I did a program at a huge
global financial institution
in DC-- DC-based, a
couple months ago.
It was a big women's program.
There were hundreds
of women there.
And they were in a place of
some degree of discouragement.
And what I learned was that
the organization had recently
done a survey on who
people preferred as bosses.
And men and women both perceived
that having a male boss
was more desirable.
And I was fascinated by this.
So once we had done
our program, I said,
can I do some
background in here?
Can I learn a little
more about why this was?
What it is in your culture
that was responsible for that?
What I learned were two things.
First of all, in
that environment
where there were very few
women who were bosses,
women were often perceived
of as tougher bosses,
because they were
so invested in doing
things kind of
perfectly themselves.
But they seemed to
have less tolerance.
But the other thing
which relates to this,
is that men were
perceived to have
better connections in the
organization as a whole.
And people wanted
to be on a team
where their boss had
a lot of connections,
because they understood
and recognized
that was going to be good
for them down the line.
So to the extent that you're
not building alliances
and connections, that's going
to have an impact upon also
how your team perceives you.
So I think it's something
really important.
And again, building
relationships
is not always the same
thing as leveraging them.
Remember we talked about
Susan Bernstein saying,
I wish I had been able to
stand up for what I saw.
And standing up is something
we need to think about.
I have been asked
for 25 years what
women need to do to
build a stronger,
more effective
leadership presence.
Do women need to have
a firmer handshake?
Is it how we walk?
What we're wearing?
Should you carry a
purse into a meeting?
Are you making
yourself look weaker
if you're carrying a purse,
or encumbered in other ways?
It's always cosmetic
what the questions are.
But having spent
25 years working
with some of the
best women leaders--
best leaders around the world,
I've come to the conclusion
that what really builds
leadership presence is
the capacity to be present.
To be present in the moment
for the person in front of you,
for the task in front of
you, for the actual situation
that you're in.
And there is a reason that
the word presence and present
are essentially the same.
Those are connected.
And what's rather
daunting about this
is that in a 24/7 environment
that we're part of,
where technology is a part
of how we're interacting
all the time, it can be
difficult to build, to be
responsive, to do your
job, but in the course
of doing that, also build the
kind of leadership presence
that gives you real
strengths and makes
you perceived of as a leader.
Because the
environment we're part
of is inherently distracting.
Years ago, before I
got into this at all,
I said I had done a lot of
speech writing for executives.
And it was so
fascinating because when
I'd go to conferences and
working with the executives,
you could always tell who the
executive was, because he--
never saw a woman in those
days-- he was unencumbered.
And he didn't have anything
he was worried about.
Everybody else was worried
about what was going on.
But he didn't need to worry
about where are my notes?
Or what's happened?
Or where is this?
Or, what's the right door?
Or oh, it's raining.
How am I going to
get to the door?
Or carrying a raincoat.
Fine.
Things were taken care of
and he could be present.
Sometimes he wasn't.
Sometimes he was the kind of guy
who couldn't look at anybody,
couldn't look
anybody in the eye.
But he had that capacity.
And what's
fascinating is to look
at the extent to which the
environment we're part of
can undermine our
capacity to be present,
but even as it does so,
it weakens our ability
to really manifest to presence.
And I do think that
it can be harder
for women partly
because of our radar.
That capacity to be noticing how
things are landing on somebody.
Or how engaged someone is.
Noticing what's
going on in the room.
That radar-like capacity,
while it has a real strength,
also has the potential
to undermine our ability
to be fully present.
So what I've seen are
a number of practices,
I share three today,
that really are
helpful in being able
to maintain the capacity
to be fully present,
which I believe
is absolutely
essential for sending
a message about your
potential as a leader.
People get that.
We get it at a level that's
here, rather than here.
We understand when someone is
present, or when they're not.
And we understand
it across cultures.
That's something else I
think it really important.
People can recognize.
You have all these
training programs,
if you're in a meeting,
and someone's a Muslim,
don't show the
bottom of your shoe,
and all these kinds
of techniques.
We get it.
Communicating across culture.
But people understand
and recognize
if you are present
across cultures.
That's something that
really translates.
So I believe it is a tremendous
advantage to all of us
to think about what
do we need to do
to be as present as we can.
What I've seen work is, number
one, be your own HR department.
And by that I mean,
think through what
policies, what practices, do
you need to incorporate into how
you do things, that
protect your ability
to be thoughtful and effective
rather than constantly
responding.
What works for you?
We're are all
different in this way.
And that's why I say be your
own HR department, because this
isn't something that can
be handed down as policy.
If we're really starting
from the point of what
is going to help me be present,
and be effective, and be
thoughtful, what do I need to
do to enable that to happen?
How do I need to use my
time, and my technology,
and my interactions in ways
that will really support that?
So some real mindfulness and
intention around doing that.
When we're going
into a new project,
negotiate our time
needs in advance.
And as much as we can--
it's not an ideal world--
but negotiate that in time.
And maybe sell up.
I did some work at Microsoft
and this woman that
was a general manager there,
when I was talking about this,
she said, what I
did is I realized
that the constant
stream of tasks
was really undermining me.
And I talked to
my boss and said,
I'm going to do an experiment
where I turn this off
for a certain number
of hours a day.
And I will not be able
to necessarily respond.
She said, and I was able to
kind of sell that to him.
And then I was able to--
speaking of data-- document
how it improved
my effectiveness.
So that became part of my policy
for how I managed my time.
So I think that's setting
policies is really important.
The second thing-- and I think
this is particularly important
for women in my experience--
is to recognize and address
compulsive or
addicting multitasking.
Women often take pride in
their capacity to multitask.
And the world we live
in, we all multitask.
I'm not advocating--
sometimes I've given this talk
and I get into the
elevator, and some woman's
in the elevator
on her cell phone
and she says, oh I-- I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
She's almost defending me,
because she feels like, oh, she
thinks I'm multitasking.
We live in a world that
requires a certain degree
of multitasking, but it
is important to recognize
that while it is efficient,
there is always a cost.
Because if you are doing
two things at once, you,
by definition, cannot be
present for both of them.
Your attention is divided.
Your attention is fractured.
You're more likely
to make mistakes.
And it is inherently
more stressful.
Because stress is produced
when our attention is divided.
Not when we're working hard.
That's what is stressful.
I've gotta do this.
Oh, what time is the
plane gonna come,
and then I've got to
get there, and maybe I
should recalculate--
that's where stress lives.
Stress lives in
divided attention.
And the more
present one can be--
and again, I feel that
I've watched this,
I've witnessed this
by being exposed
to highly effective
senior executives.
They have the resources to
help them to be present,
because they're not
worrying about the details.
Most of us don't
have that luxury.
We have to sweat the details.
But the more we can
do that in a way
where we are mindful of
where is this addictive?
Where is this habitual?
How important is it that I
respond to this right now?
The more we can protect
our effectiveness,
the more leadership presence
we will be able to effect,
and the more we'll be
able to represent and gain
respect for an understanding
of what our vision is.
And the final thing is,
as Buddhists recognize,
presence is a practice.
Being presence is a practice.
And that's what meditation
and meditational
pursuits are about.
They're a way of
practicing being present.
And presence is not something
you can just tell yourself,
I'm going to be present.
I've decided, starting now.
I'm going to be fully present.
It doesn't work that way.
It's something that you
incorporate into your being.
And you do that
through practice.
Thich Nat Hanh, the
Vietnamese monk,
has a wonderful
practice that he uses
when he works with
people in offices.
He says, every time that phone
rings, every time you hear
that bell, use it like
monks in a monastery.
Use a monastery bell.
Take one second to call yourself
to attention and to present.
Take a breath when you hear it.
Let your practice
be to remind you
when you hear a bell, when
you hear a text ping, whatever
it is, I'm here now.
I'm present.
I'm in the moment.
I am here.
And if you can do
that, you can begin
to develop that muscle that
enables you to be present.
And by the way, you'll
be a lot more effective
when you pick up the phone.
Rather than, yeah.
You'll be, can I help you?
That's much more present.
So thinking of it in
terms of presence.
And I think this is something
that's very powerful.
I said the presence
translates across culture.
It even translates across
species, which is a big deal.
Anybody watch Cesar?
The Dog Whisperer.
That's all he does.
You know, the dog owners
walk into their house,
the dog goes nuts.
Cesar walks in, the
dog is total attention.
And all it is, is he is
fully present and aware.
So that can translate
across species.
Anybody who's tried
to ride a horse
knows how effective
that is, if you're
thinking about 10
different things at once.
So being able to bring
that practice into what
you do is going to
help you represent
your vision with real power,
and authority, and influence,
and, oh by the way, you'll
be much less stressed
and distracted in the process.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned Sheryl Sandberg.
I'm curious what are your--
SALLY HELGESEN: Mentioned what?
AUDIENCE: Sheryl
Sandberg's book.
SALLY HELGESEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was actually
curious on your thoughts
in terms of the "lean in"
kind of decree for women.
SALLY HELGESEN:
Well first of all,
I think Sheryl's book was one
of the great contributions
of the last 10 years.
What I see is that it has
gotten companies thinking
at a much higher
level about what
they need to do to engage women.
And it's made it acceptable--
I did a program at a big energy
company that was very
traditional and top down.
And it had a male panel,
which I was moderating.
And all four men on the panel
showed up carrying her book.
To show how on board they were.
So it's kind of given men-- I
think because of her status--
permission to be interested
in this issue, which
is extremely important.
And many, many of the
points she made, I thought,
were really very important.
It doesn't just
happen-- leadership.
It involves that stepping up
and making that commitment
and saying, I really
want this to work.
This may not be the place.
I may need to go
to another place,
but I really want to
invest in my career.
And I think that's
what she was saying.
And I so dislike the criticism
that-- well, easy for her
to say.
She's got all these resources.
That that's not the point.
The point is she was
encouraging and saying
you can have a richer,
fuller, more meaningful life
if you invest yourself
in your career.
On the other hand,
this propensity
of women to look at the
actual quality of their day
is something that is
pretty deeply ingrained.
I don't think it has
to be an either/or.
On one hand, it doesn't
have to be so non-strategic.
Well, I'm not enjoying
this particular job.
I've had five bad days in a row.
I think I'm going to quit.
That is not leaning in.
That is not stepping up.
That's getting discouraged.
What we find is that over time,
if day after day after day,
the experience of work is
profoundly unsatisfying, women
are more likely to
say, that salary,
that position was not
worth it, because I am just
not enjoying my life.
I believe this is one
of the great gifts
that women have to
bring to the workplace.
Because I've read
a lot of research
about the millennial
generation and what they value.
And it's much more similar
to what women value.
It's that interest in what
is the quality of my life.
I'm moving into organizations.
I know I'm going to be
working 60 hours a week if I'm
going to get anywhere.
I know how much my job is
going to be all-consuming.
I need to be able to enjoy it.
I need to be able to feel as
if my contribution is really
valued.
I want to feel a part
of what I'm doing.
And that's what we
hear from the men
and women of that
millennial generation, who
come in-- you know, people
say oh, they're so entitled.
Well first of all,
their parents told
them, good job when they
picked up a quarter.
They've been told over
and over, you're terrific,
you can do anything.
And so of course they
have that attitude.
And I happen to
believe that attitude
can be very adaptive
in today's workplace,
because so much
is expected of us.
But one of the
things I often say,
and I say to executives
who are saying,
women seem to feel like
work should be enjoyable.
I say, be grateful.
Because you have an
opportunity to think
through the experience
of work at this place.
And prepare yourself for that
next generation, who's attitude
is much more likely to be
similar to that of women.
So this is again, I
believe what happened--
like with those
leadership competencies--
is women are to a degree,
on the cutting edge
of how organizations
will need to adapt
to be able to really engage
their talent at the highest
level.
And that it is helpful.
It behooves-- to use an old
fashioned word-- organizations
to be able to listen to that.
And it's helpful for us in terms
of really making that case.
I did not see in Sheryl's
book, this big divide
between stepping up and valuing
the quality of your every day.
Obviously every day isn't
going to be a picnic.
And there are days
that are going
to be extremely difficult.
It's really over time when you
begin to perceive a missed it,
or mismatch.
Like the woman
Susan Bernstein did,
as a result of feeling I cannot
be authentic in this job.
But it's also
possible-- I mean again,
that woman, Ellen Isaacs that
I met out here in the Valley,
who felt so discouraged
because she felt like her boss
didn't see what she really had,
what her best qualities were.
There are ways we can
address that if we
have an awareness of it.
There are ways we
can make that better.
And she reported that this made
an enormous difference to her,
that she felt like her boss
really noticed her, and noticed
what was best about her.
And that was profoundly
rewarding to her.
And gave her much more
a feeling of freedom,
and much more feeling
like she really
fit with this organization.
So I think the
message is hopeful.
I felt Sheryl's message was
very hopeful and very hands-on
in terms of specific advice.
And as I said, I've been
doing this 25 years.
And one of the
advantages of that
is being able to take a
big picture long-term view.
And I believe this is
the best time I have ever
seen in 25 years, for women
to be able to make an impact
and help their organizations
really use their best talents.
It takes being able to
articulate and understand
the power of what
those best talents are.
But I think we're in the
time where organizations
are certainly, in my view, more
ready to hear that than they
have been in decades.
So I wish you luck.
And I thank you.